the jurgen experience that was my first
time after the sunsal fight
since the km is a ghaki fight that i
didn't get injured i tore tendons and
ligaments and
stem cells out for eight weeks to you
know and then you know
so i was like man i was back in the gym
monday hungry to go and then [ __ ]
covet
get covered get title shot i'm like i'm
about to fight figgy at 25.
you got kovid bad right were you did you
get coveted in the were you in the
middle of training when you got it like
were you worn out
dead i was doing one training session
and actually i started the whoop
and i was like man like my recovery
score is one percent in the morning my
hry
was like 13 it was one percent for like
a week
and i would only do one workout and then
i'd have to cancel on chris and my lot
i'm like one percent is
dead dude that's crazy but then i was
like you know i'm gonna go ride the bike
you know
i was getting on those bikes doing you
know 50 to 100 mile rides and just
suffering because i had vertigo really
bad so i couldn't get in those
uncompromised positions that
when did you start experiencing vertigo
vertigo was my first symptom
of copen not knowing and then i had did
you think it was head injury i thought
my uh my doctor i went and saw he's like
that's a concussion i'm like dude i
didn't get hit
hard and sparring my fights like i
worked on defense a lot like i know i
would know if it was
a concussive blow that gave me vertigo
and
um what did you experience it after
training did you experience honestly it
was during grappling i was like
grappling
you didn't like collide heads or
anything nope just went into a scramble
and
next thing you know i was just like
fighting the hands off and the whole
room was spinning
and i was actually training with uriah
and i was like man he's like yeah all
right
i'm like what's going on i was like kind
of like didn't want to end
in the round so i just kind of like
closed my eyes and like held onto his
hand so he wouldn't choke me you know he
was taking my back so i was
finished around and i was like man i
just don't feel good i was nauseated for
a few days
um so i went to my doctor he was giving
me like anti-nausea medicine that was
making me so
much more tired than i was because i was
fatigued from from training i was trying
to train through it i was like i have a
world title coming
up in eight weeks like i have to get
down to 25 and my weight was good
um i wasn't restricting any calories you
felt something was off with your body
besides the vertigo
my body felt like i just was for about a
three week period when i was training
and
i didn't feel like myself at all and
just mental clarity was
was so do you think during that time you
had crovid the whole time
i think so you know that is crazy and
that makes sense that
it hit you so hard because you never
gave your body a break and you were
beating yourself up while you were
fighting off covet
well that i think what happened was the
kidney infection in the beginning of
2020. i was on all those antibiotics
i was on five different antibiotics
people don't even notice two weeks
before the fight with the sun sao the
infection came back
so i had to go to another infectious
disease doctor that my doctor
hill found in sacramento this lady was
amazing did two blood cultures
found out got all the reports from the
hospital in jersey the reports from the
specialists in cleveland
studied those all in a day got a blood
culture i was on the wrong antibiotics i
didn't kill the infection just basically
put a band-aid over it
so i had to go 10 days to iv fusion
center to get antibiotic drip for 10
days while i'm training two weeks before
the fight
oh my god i didn't let any of the ufc or
anybody know
i told ali it was kind of what was going
on because i just needed to get in that
octagon i was like dude just put me in
that
gun i know that it'll happen like get me
there healthy and i'll be good so but
that [ __ ] with your endurance in a big
way yeah iv
antibiotics are ruthless it was tough
man it was uh
and my strength conditioning coach we
were having the hardest time
i was hovering around you know i was
getting my heart rate up 187 and then
i couldn't get it below and like hover
at 150 which i'm fine at santa 150 and
going up and being in that 150 to 180
zone that i could be there for a while
but we're working on the aerobic system
so to drop it you know
i just couldn't drop it it took about
the last
week of training before i flew out to
the fight week to finally get my heart
rate in like
35's like after a hard like a minute 30
push and then
drop it down so i noticed something like
that was it but mentally i was like
it's good so so two weeks out you did
you had to do a 10
day cycle of iv antibiotics in a 10-day
of
um oral what yeah i was on antibiotics
for literally
five months almost from jersey i was on
five different antibiotics
from the hospital so from the ascension
fight how many days did you have when
you weren't on antibiotics
before the fight i mean i declared that
i had i was on antibiotics all the way
up to the fight
you know i was taking a lot of
antibiotics right yeah i was talking so
you were taking probiotics to counteract
the effects
of a lot of probiotics yeah what are you
taking um frankie edgar's wife sent me
uh
she would do they were they took care of
me when i was in jersey like hooked it
up like coach brought me pizza in the
hospital he was like
it was during coco pizza but don't you
have to cut weight i don't cut weight to
35.
really dude i'm like right now probably
144
oh wow like i don't i and i stay you
know strong and fast and this is why i
feel good at the fight 35 yeah
i have to just diet a little bit like
everyone else does for 25 that's what
everyone's making is a big yeah we're
going to 25 it's not
so you basically beat your immune system
up
while you had covid and then because of
that you got covered really bad
yes yeah so tell me what it was like i
was horrible i mean i had the vertigo
was the first symptom right and then
when did they test you for kovitz i
didn't get tested ty went down to
mike tyson's ranch we were working with
the smart cups company we're all
sponsored by him doing digital videos
and
it was our first kind of getting
athletes together because they started
doing fighters boxers
and some wwe kurt angle was there so i
had to do like a rapid test like we just
did here
and um i waited to wait a while and
they like hey we want you to do another
one i'm like all right cool like we just
didn't see some things
we liked i was like all right i'm like
waiting for an hour
do another one i'm like what did you
guys another test yeah what'd you guys
see i'm like
oh you failed the first one i'm like
well that's a subtle way you're telling
it like i want to stay away from
everybody like you know everyone's
coming up to me and
so i tested there in august um and then
i went you know quarantined
went home did the whole did you do any
medication what did you do um i did a
z-pack
um i got on an inhaler because i had
pneumonia i got pneumonia
vertigo and then i did it like a 21 day
because i had it so bad i kept getting
tested like every three weeks
and you kept having i kept having i did
molecular tests which was like night you
know
some of the best ones to do is that the
pcr test yeah we're talking about
yeah and just kept negative negative my
doctor's like hey we're going to quit
testing you you know like
you mean positive you keep testing
positive yeah positive for it
yeah and i'm like dang this is this is
crazy i mean and i had
started to have the symptoms going away
like pneumonia was fine my lungs were
good like i felt it like i was
that's when i started cycling a lot um
so i was out there just pushing the
lungs that's what my doctor said was the
best thing to do is
riding that bike that much is getting
those lungs to keep working because you
have pneumonia really bad
jesus christ wow like i felt horrible i
thought cycling was one of the hardest
things to do
isn't it funny because you would think
like most people would think that a guy
who's a
world championship caliber fighter is
the type of guy who would get coveted
and it would just burn right through his
system but because you were
training while you had it and beating
yourself up it just got
deep into you deep i mean it it took
over my body but
i think honestly from the kidney
infection beyond the antibodies my
immune system was so weak how much time
was it between the kidney infection the
antibiotics and then getting coveted
dude i literally got out of the hospital
and i texted dana like hey i heard you
did a press conference about having a
fight um my kidney levels are good i'm
waiting for maybe have to do a biopsy
but i want to fight he's like all right
work on it i was like begging john so
you got covered
right away um so i then i uh after the
fight
yeah i had uh so june to august oh okay
but uh so it was from the kidney
infection the fight two fight camps you
know basically
one didn't happen uh recovering i've
been building myself
back up from where i was at getting
ready to fight a sunset the first time
in march
you know i literally had to start
walking on a treadmill for a couple
weeks to get my
i was in rough shape rough shape and i
started training at my business
partner's house he had a home gym
because everything was closed
uriah's gym wasn't open he said dude i
got a treadmill i got weights
kettlebells you know anna kettlebells
and so i went over there and just
started to
to train and i'm like i'm getting myself
ready and it was brutal
brutal brutal training getting back in
there this is pre-coveted
this is pre-covered this is a kidney
kitty infection jesus christ
but so your body was obviously already
compromised oh yeah i was yeah very
confident i still on antibiotics
he still had me on antibiotics to clean
out the infection i was on it for
like a 30 day antibiotic from the
hospital so august
you get covid how long before it clears
your system how long
before you start feeling good months
like i literally
i went to miami and worked with this
company called amino wells and they did
like kind of injections uh
we talked about kind of stem cell
injections throughout my body arms
um and i kind of started to feeling a
lot better at like the week after that i
did a month
on the injections with the three
milliliters a week
and i felt really good body felt good
clarity went away
i actually had to go to arizona the mayo
clinic
dana thought i had meniere's disease so
i went and saw his doctor that did his
surgery
to give him shot in his ears did all
these testings hearing tests
um did you have ringing in your ears i
had ringing bad at my left ear and
there's um
i have a loss of uh hearing in this year
and they don't know why i think maybe
because i'm this is my lead
lead and you get hit in the left ear
that's all i can say i'm like i don't
know i haven't shot a gun without
you know anything like that you know
trying to just figure out why it's
ringing
it makes like this popping noise um and
i was just getting so
like dizzy i couldn't even do anything
i'm saying so that's probably ten
contributed to the vertigo for sure
right
they said it wasn't officially it's ear
things yeah they said like crystals i
had vertigo before
i work with upmc i was out for a whole
year my pro debut broke my hand had
vertigo from crystals being out of the
air went to the upmc crystals
crystals yeah was that an irregular tube
that was throwing my equilibrium off
which basically is positional vertigo
a lot of it's that's the most common one
you know a lot of people just you know
they can sneeze wrong or
do something sleep wrong on their neck
and they have vertigo and there's a
maneuver you do
to put it back but it wasn't positional
vertigo it was just literally coveted
that
had me so messed up so your body was so
compromised from the
antibiotics the kidney infection a
second kidney infection
so you were just basically getting your
your health back which is crazy that you
beat a sun sao
in that state yeah because you could you
had to be clearly compromised there's no
way you could have been 100
if you were going if you went through
that much antibiotics before that fight
but i think that goes back to the my
mental state where it was that i knew
that i needed to get in that octagon and
change this around i was not living a
life like this i was tired of living
on a three-fight skid i was ready to get
back in there and when you know
like for me like i like we talked about
earlier with the tgs fights i don't have
to go in there and be angry and upset
and
want to rip this head i got there hate
this guy i have hatred for this guy
it's a flip to switch like when you know
you have it in you you don't
you know and that that's been bread in
me i've have it um
so i just needed to get in there i was
like not taking no for an answer i mean
my coaches and stuff like oh i don't
know if you're going to make it you know
and coach mark i'd call him because we
basically did
i would film my pad work and my
sparring rounds and send it to coach on
whatsapp and then he would break
everything down do more of this do less
of that looking good looking fast on the
you know your left hook counter off
things like that so we
did virtually you know
camp through there so then when he came
out so i kept working the codes to you
know keep working your codes keep
working you know and
make sure you're doing under nine things
like that um
then when we came to fight week it was
just
so talk me through you getting you got
coveted tested
in august at the tyson joe you knew that
you had it
when when are you free of it like
this is the first test that i've passed
since really today
my doctor would test that february
february yeah jesus see how excited i
was
yeah dude i'm free i'm free of it it was
literally you know a couple months of
having it testing it to where my doctors
i'm not going to send out any more tests
because there were 72 hour return ones
and
every time you did it you had it every
time i did and this is for months
um tested my son he didn't have it i
mean we were i was your wife didn't get
it
um she ended up getting it um but it
wasn't as severe it was
it was a couple months ago that she got
it um two months ago her twin got it and
it was kind of you know they were sick
but not like
what i had like i was just yeah well
you're a perfect example of
you know obviously you're a super
healthy guy and
an elite athlete but when you put
yourself through training camp
there's only one way to get in shape you
got to beat yourself up
there's no there's no other way around
it's true and when you
are so tough that you push through even
though you had covid
and you let that [ __ ] get deep into your
system there's a lesson in there for
people
you know because there's tough tough's
important yeah you don't get where you
get without being tough
but there's there's also you you got to
be you got to
be able to take a step back and go it's
not
wise to push sometimes
and i think honestly if i got tested
before having kovan
then i mean before i first had the first
like i've had
you probably never got it you probably
would have had it for a couple of weeks
or whatever
and yeah exactly it wouldn't be as it
took over my body then i came back and i
hit pads the first time like dude i'm
i'm in great shape because i was cycling
100 miles you know we had a
hard pace we were riding four or five
times a week you know building the legs
up and
so i started hitting pads again i was
excited like i'm back in the gym i can
be around people
because on the bike i was just on the
bike trail on the road just you know
suffering on the bike
came back hit pads the first time and
man i my bicep was so sore
and that i remember going to sleep that
night and waking up excruciating pain
wow and my bicep was just filled up with
blood like this i thought i tore my
bicep so i went to my doctor
and he ultrasounded it and he thought it
was a distant bicep tear
you know deemed it that i'm like i gotta
call dana and tell them like hey i'm
just turning my bicep i'm gonna then get
the mri get the mri
nothing's torn it was a uh guy then i
had to go get a urgent ultrasound
i tore my vein in half and it ripped in
half
wow and then i had three blood clots so
i was
immediately they started injecting me
with blood thinners i was on i've been
on blood thinners for
you know since yeah
this is because of cove that's another
thing that happens with people that
severe cases of covid they get blood
clots didn't know
and my business partner jeremy perkins
he owns
uh pnp medical which they work with
covid or they work with
blood clots they have you know some the
devices they sell to doctors and
hospitals
and the whole time he's like dude i
think you have a blood clot i'm like
there's no way i have a blood clot
that's the number one silent killer in
in the nation is blood clots because
people don't know they have it
i had three of them in my arm didn't
even know that's crazy i just had like
my arm was sore for a while so you're on
blood thinners now
i just finished up my last i was on
blood pressure for almost three months
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience